j'adore les maisons rustiques et j'adore
les maisons qui ont qui sont
confortables mais pas luxueuse voilà je
n'aime pas le luxe l'éclaboussure du
luxe
[Musique]
à la madrague un luxe sans éclaboussure
en revanche ailleurs à saint tropez et
maisons qui valent plusieurs milliards
qui sont toutes en marbre blanc qui sont
avec des décors complètement insensé moi
je trouve que ça va pas du tout au bord
de la mer et dans un petit pays comme
celui ci est plus en tout cas ça va pas
avec moi vous voulez fait inviter dans
ces maisons luxueuses absa pour
m'inviter on m'a vite mais je n'y vais
jamais ça m'ennuie j'ai peur d'attraper
un rhume c'est trop froid et les gens
les gens ils peuvent avoir de la chaleur
humaine ça suffit pas je crois que les
maisons ressemble aux gens qui habitent
dedans les gens sont aussi froid que les
maisons ici non je crois que c'est très
vrai ce que je dis je crois que le cadre
dans lequel on vit ressemble à la
personne qui vit dedans
en tout cas moi je ressemble à mes
maisons sûrement
[Musique]
mais brigitte bardot c'est désormais le
combat pour les animaux alors à la
madrague on oublie tout
j'y pense tout le temps ces animaux
martyrs mais j'essaye de reprendre du
courage et de la force
alors avec le soleil avec la mer avec
les choses très simples de la vie avec
mes animaux qui sont eux des animaux
heureux je reprends plein de courage et
je repars me battre à paris je repars
agresser les gens méchants avec les
animaux alors justement vous paraissez
être quelqu'un d'agressif voire de
déplaisant puisque vous donner des
leçons aux gens ce que vous croyez pas
que si vous étiez aussi souriante que
maintenant le message passerait mieux
non je crois que dans la vie quand on se
bat pour quelque chose on n'a jamais
fait la guerre en souriant
il faut être dur ferme savoir ce qu'on
veut et aller jusqu'au bout des choses
maintenant en ce moment je ne sais pas
la guerre et quand je ne sais pas la
guerre moi je suis la femme la plus
souriante et la plus heureuse du monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors cette madrague et beaucoup de gens
qui veulent la voir quand tu arrives à
saint tropez est ce qui va arriver a
pénétré jusqu'à l'endroit où nous nous
trouvons banon non parce que c'est pas
amusé mais c'est vrai que c'est le point
de ralliement c'est l'arc de triomphe de
saint tropez maintenant la madrague les
gens viennent ici en quarts en
délégation avec leur pique nique avec
des billets de 10 francs à la main pour
visiter font la queue devant le portail
un jour j'ouvre mon portail pour sentir
que ma voiture et je tombe sur un car
rempli d'allemands qui attendaient bien
sagement en faisant la queue que ça
ouvre à deux heures pour visiter
enfin cesser complètement fou que c'est
une maison qui est devenu un endroit de
un point de rendez-vous du monde entier
et en mer c'est la même chose alors par
la mer par la terre où les bateaux
passent là devant les gens viennent à
pied parce le nez par dessus les murs
essaye d'escaladé alors comme j'ai sept
chiens sales et dissuade un peu j'ai un
gentil gardien qui les dissuadent aussi
mais c'est pas très sympa très reposant
est ce que fait vivable en été non l'été
je m'en vais c'est vivable maintenant
vous êtes responsable de tous avant
gilberto alors on dit que je suis
responsable de tout ça et moi mon grand
bonheur ce serait qu'ils aient personnes
à saint tropez
alors ça va pas très bien tout ça non je
crois que dieu créa la femme a été
responsable de ça et puis le fait que
c'est un ravissant petit village aussi
qui serait devenu sûrement ce qu'il est
devenu avec ou sans moi
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce que vous pensez de
saint tropez
alors aujourd'hui je trouve que c'est
devenu la foire à neuneu la fête à
neuneu les galeries lafayette à
l'horizontale et que c'est dommage parce
que ça gâche tout les gens ne voient
même pas le paysage ils viennent pour
dire qu'ils ont été à saint-tropez pour
dire qu'ils ont vu la madrague pour
essayer de voir des vedettes de cinéma
comme michel morgant romy schneider et
autres qui ont acheté des maisons ici
depuis quelques temps face et c'est
devenu un espèce de rendez-vous du
snobisme et de et de la popularité
les gens ne voient même plus la beauté
du site parce que c'est très joli
[Musique]